- Après deux semaines
d'audiences, les révélationsouou
ont encore de quoi étonner.
Cette fois, la surprise vient
de cet avocat, qui conseillaitui
des camionneurs.
Selon Keith Wilson,
à la cause du convoi coulaient
des infoatations confidentielles
aux manifestants et aux
organisateurs. Il allègue
de la police d'Ottawa,
dea a police provinciale
de l'Ontario, de la GRC
et même du Service canadienriri.
Les organisateurs recevaient
des in
comme des détails sur
les opérations policières
planifiées, permettant aux
organisateurs de se préparer.
L'avocat a même eu accès à une
copie d'un courriel d'un haut
de l'Ontario qui exposait
s s tensions avec le
Service de police d'Ottawa.
Des failles qui ont de quoiiéié.
PIERRE-YVES BOURDUAS, ex-sous-
commissaire adjoint à la GRC
- Il peut y avoir un dangerimmir
les policiers qui sont déployés
sur le terrain.
- Écoutez, ça n'a aucun bon
se
- Cet élu bloquiste est
estomaqué.
RHÉAL FORTIN, député bloquiste,
Rivière-du-Nord
devraient déclencher une enquête
ppur chercher à identifier
les sources de ces fuites-la,
parce que c'est pas acceptable.
- Mais le coup de main aux
arrêté là. Cet ancien militaire,
qui n'était plus dans l'armée
au moment du convoi, a expliqué
à la Commission comment il a mis
ses compétences logistiques
les efforts d'approvisionnement
en essence, en nourriture et
en argent pour les manifestants
du convoi, notamment.
En parallèle les autorités
organisateurs du convoi
imprévisleles, connus pour
leur propos incendiaires
sur les médias sociaux.
vavavavavavavavavavavavavavavavc
des balles", avait clamé
le sulfureux Pat King sur les
médias sociaux. Des propos pris
hors contexte, aurururururururut
un appel à la violence et
se justifie, parlant plutôt de
scénarios possibles, une
prédicti
empêchés de manifester.
Déjà, les corps policiers
en avaient plein les bras,
surpris par l'ampleur de la
manifestation eteieieieieieieies
groupes installés à Ottawa.
Mais les fuites dans leurs
propres rangs exposent l'ampleur
la réponse policière.
Ici Lisis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Ottawa.